growth is the number one priority of
this government it has become basically
a mantra basically a prayer which is
don't worry about anything else just
grow just grow it's basically reached
the point where growth has become
essentially a code word from the very
rich which is I'm an idiot I don't
understand this problem I have no real
solutions but just grow we hear
these kinds of arguments the problem
with Britain is we're just not
productive enough if the fundamental
problem is a lack of productivity why Is
wealth of the richest people in the
country the richest people in the world
Millionaires and billionaires why are
these people's wealth exploding through
the ceiling I always remember in the
middle of the depth of the cost of
living crisis the financial times had an
article and the headline was will the
Boom in luxury goods ever stop if you
live in a country and a world where
living standards of ordinary people are
collapsing and living standards of the
riches are exploding through the room
stock markets are exploding to new
alltime highs the gold price massive new
Ori yesterday do you really think the
problem is productivity growth do you
not think there might be a deeper
problem with inequality it's very very
important that that people like you
understand inequality is growing and
inequality is growing very quickly and
when inequality grows quickly living
standards for the rich increase and
living standards for for the poor fult
people like our are very wealthy
politicians they're not going to do
anything about it it has to be you it
has to be me we have to scream at these
politicians and say the problem is not
economic growth the problem is growth of
inequality of wealth if you don't fix it
our living stands will collapse it's not
growth it's inequality stupid we have to
fix it thank you